durchseuchung bei kindern das sagt ja
das kanzleramt das gilt es um jeden
preis zu verhindern und die andere seite
die sagte der moment mal also die
wenigsten kinder erkranken tatsächlich
schwerer an corona jetzt lasst uns alles
versuchen neue schulschließungen neue
unterbrechungen des schulalltags zu
verhindern und lasst uns vernünftig sein
und nicht ganze klassen wieder in
quarantäne schicken einfach unterricht
unterricht unterricht darüber wollen wir
jetzt sprechen mit der ehemaligen
familienministerin kristina schröder die
uns zugeschaltet ist schön guten tag
frau schröder
wenn sie das hören durchseuchung der
kinder ist dass das ist natürlich eine
ärztliche und medizinische begriff aber
einer der im moment schon benutzt wird
um uns angst zu machen und den kindern
ja also das ist ganz klar ein
kampfbegriff
und wenn man mal guckt was ist in den
anderen europäischen ländern passiert
man muss sich ja klar machen deutschland
hatte ja an den schulen mit die
härtesten maßnahmen ganz europa werden
gerade für die mittelstufe die schulen
und längst dicht andere länder wie zum
beispiel spanien oder die schweiz haben
in der zweiten dritten und werde die
schulen überhaupt nicht mehr geschlossen
und dort sind auch keine katastrophe
passiert
und wir sollten endlich auch mal nach
anderen ländern gucken und nicht immer
nur hier in deutschland die größten
mögliche panik auf dem rücken unserer
kinder spüren
wenn wir jetzt schauen welche maßnahmen
derzeit ergriffen werden wir sprechen
seit ich weiß gar nicht wie lange über
luftfilter für die schulen darum ein
konzept zu haben für die schulen haben
sie das gefühl dass derzeit das
überhaupt vorliegt jetzt da wir den
herbst und winter steuern
ich glaube schon dass die kultusminister
wirklich in den meisten bundesländern
sehr viel dafür tun um präsenzunterricht
stattfinden zu lassen und da halte ich
nicht luft reinigungsgeräte für das
wichtigste ich bin der luft
reinigungsgeräte gut ich bin finde es
gut wenn sie in den schulen angeschafft
wurden aber der eigentlich entscheidende
punkt ist dass wir eine politische
entscheidung treffen und zwar die
politische entscheidung dass wir die
schulen offen lassen
dass wir nicht weiter die maßnahme auf
dem rücken der kinder austragen denn das
alte argument für die schulschließung
die wurden ja nicht die schulen
geschlossen um die kinder zu schützen
sondern die schulen wurden geschlossen
mit dem argument sonst würden sie das
infektionsgeschehen treiben und da
könnten wohl mehrere gruppen darunter
leiden wohl der rappe gruppen können
sich jetzt aber impfen lassen und damit
ist das argument für schulschließungen
weg aber das ist noch nicht alles schule
ist ja nicht nur lernen sondern schult
auch lebensort das heißt schule muss
auch wieder kindgemäße bedingungen
bilden es müssen klassenfahrten
stattfinden es müssen
theateraufführungen stattfinden und ich
habe eine siebenjährige tochter eine
zweitklässlerin die geht wie fast alle
grundschulkinder auch in die betreuung
das heißt die ist acht stunden in der
schule und die trägt acht stunden lang
maske und was wir da so kleinen kindern
zumuten mit einem zweifelhaften nutzen
kinder die geimpft sind das man an
tschuldigung nicht kinder die geimpften
die getestet sind das muss man sich ja
immer klar machen das ist wirklich was
wir da den kleinen kindern zumuten ich
weiß dass viele die keinen direkten
kontakt zu kindern hab das ding gar
nicht mehr klar ist die maßnahmen für
kinder in deutschland sind härter als
für die allermeisten erwachsenen
empfinden ihre kinder das so frau
schröder denn das finde ich eine
interessante beobachtung kenne ich aus
meinem alltagsleben dass sie selber das
und das finde ich erschreckend gar nicht
mehr so empfinden weil dies so gelernt
haben die machen das jetzt zwei jahre
die sitzen seit zwei jahren mit der
maske im unterricht und halten das für
die normalität
das klar meine siebenjährige kann sich
an die zeit von corona kaum erinnern die
dreijährige schon gar nicht und dann
hast du immer die kinder machen das doch
so toll
kleine kinder die halten sich an das was
was die lehrer sagen das sind
autoritätspersonen und da wird sich die
kleinen meine kleinen braven mädchen und
meine tochter hat mir jetzt auch erzählt
brot brot gebissen und da ganz schnell
die maske wieder aufgezogen und dann
kann ich mich nicht freuen sondern ich
finde das ja mir macht das eigentlich
auch sorge wie sehr die kinder das
internalisiert haben und damit ja auch
ihre unbeschwertheit verloren haben und
sich ständig in diesen pandemischen
modus befinden und die kinder auch und
jetzt wieder normalität und ein normales
kinderleben davon sind wir aber das muss
man ganz klar sagen weit entfernt wir
hören ja auch von beispielen an schulen
da müssen die kinder draußen essen bei
wind und wetter ist egal weil das ist
sicherer sie haben die masken pflicht
angesprochen mein sohn geht es ja
genauso acht stunden den ganzen tag mit
der maske und er kennt das schon gar
nicht anders ich denke du bist mir schon
auch ans impfen was finden sie kann man
überhaupt noch lehrerinnen und lehrer
die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen in
diesem beruf arbeiten lassen
also ich denke auch dass wir das wird
dass man darüber reden muss denn
natürlich diese lehrer die haben sich in
diesem beruf begeben und dort gibt es
haben sie damit müssen sie auch quasi
gewissen schutz pflichten einhalten
und deswegen ist es schon mal eine frage
ob man eventuell ist wirklich zu lassen
kann wenn sie dann einfach sagen wir
sind nicht geimpft ob man sie vielleicht
dann sagt ja dann müsst ihr euch halt
vielleicht innerhalb des lehrerberufs
möglichkeiten suchen wo ihr nicht direkt
mit schülern in kontakt kommt zumal ja
auch gerade von lehrerverbänden der
größte druck kommt eine lehrerverbänden
kommt ja der druck weiter machten weiter
diese harten maßnahmen nicht von den
lehrern die ich kenne und ich glaube die
meisten lehrer gucken etwas fassungslos
weil es ihre eigenen verbände machen
aber die verbände selbst üben ihr einen
unglaublichen druck aus gut dass ich es
gesagt haben sonst hätten sie dann
morgens stress an der an der eigenen
schule frau stündlich eigenen die eigene
lehre ausgenommen aber das ist bei uns
zu hause ganz genau so gibt es auch viel
lob für die grundschullehrer eine letzte
frage bei uns gleich im studio wird die
bundesbildungsministerin anja karliczek
sein was ganz konkret würden sie sie
heute fragen
ich denke alle die in der
bildungspolitik unterwegs sind müssen
jetzt dafür sorgen dass die maßstäbe
wieder zurechtgerückt werden unsere
maßstäbe sind verrutscht wir müssen uns
klarmachen dass das risiko an den
schulen nur noch minimal die kinder sind
zum glück getestet was ich gut finde und
dass wir dann immer noch weiter der hat
obsessive maßnahmen haben und zum
beispiel auch bei den einschulungsfeiern
tage sozusagen nur einen elternteil oder
die gelten die geimpften großeltern
ausschließen dass ist da da ist in
unserer gesellschaft etwas schief
gelaufen also was auf die falsche bahn
gekommen und dann müssen wir alle
gemeinsam die bundesbildungsministerin
ganz vorne dran daran müssen wir
arbeiten hier wieder die maßstäbe
zurechtzurücken das sind wir unseren
kindern wirklich jetzt schnell schuldig
das sind wir unseren kindern wirklich
schuldig genau so ist beispielsweise die
einstellung meines sohnes abgelaufenen
erstanden oma und opa gm vor der tür und
auch die geschwisterkinder standen vor
der tür da bin ich ganz ihrer meinung
dass uns jeder schröder vielen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
ich danke ihnen auch alles gute
[Musik]